nous sommes de retour au travail Templeton bonjour toi
beau bébé voiture oui le frère du patron
sont-ils toujours aussi amicaux je ne peux pas
avoir mon propre frère ignorant l'art
des affaires c'est embarrassant je
m'assure que le monde aime les bébés plus que les
chiots plus que les chatons quel est le
menacer ce que les chats ne respectent pas les règles
sort des entreprises dans vos
mains de purée de pommes de terre ne le faites pas exploser juste une blague
bien sûr vous gagnez quoi de neuf cette réunion
me rend mal à l'aise
bottes que faisons-nous je vais attraper le
tigre sont  vous et votre
frère c'est mon travail sur la ligne vous avez fait le
choix de rejoindre une famille nous pouvons résoudre ce problème et
si vous vous sépariez et atterrissiez sur la
casquette oui étoile de mer dorée disent-ils
en toute justice monsieur le chat y a pensé en
premier
vous pouvez '  tu ne tue pas ce que tu ne peux pas voir il est
temps de devenir invisible maman est une sale
menteuse
[Musique]